>> NICE AND SWEET.
STEVE: THERE YOU HAVE GOT NEW
YORK GOVERNOR CUOMO RESIGNED
YESTERDAY A FAR CRY FROM THE
GUSHING MEDIA ATTENTION HE
RECEIVED ALONG WITH THE EMMY AND
$5 MILLION BOOK DEAL.
BUT OUR NEXT GUESTS SAY THE
TRUTH ABOUT HIS COVID RESPONSE
AND THE PEOPLE WHO DIED CANNOT
BE FORGOTTEN.
BRIAN: JANICE DEAN LOST BOTH OF
HER IN-LAWS MICHAEL AND DEE TO
COVID-19 IN NEW YORK NURSING
HOME FACILITIES AND ONE OF THE
MOST OUTSPOKEN VOICES TRYING TO
HOLD THE SOON-TO-BE FORMER
GOVERNOR ACCOUNTABLE.
AINSLEY: RON KIM LOST HIS UNCLE
TO COVID-19 IN A NURSING HOME AS
WELL AND THEY BOTH JOIN US NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO BOTH OF YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: JANICE, I WILL START
WITH YOU.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION
YESTERDAY?
>> I’M EMOTIONAL BECAUSE IT’S
FIRST TIME I’M SEEING
ASSEMBLYMAN RON KIM WHO HAS
BECOME CLOSE TO ME AND MY FAMILY
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS AND SO
GRATEFUL, GRATEFUL, GRATEFUL TO
HIM AND HIS OUTSPOKENESS.
HIS JOB WAS TOUGH, YOU KNOW, AS
AN ASSEMBLYMAN DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND HAD GOVERNOR GOVERNOR CUOMO
HIM AND SCREAMING AT HIM.
I’M SO GRATEFUL FOR YOU, RON
KIM.
STEVE: RON, WE APPRECIATE YOU
COMING ON OVER THE LAST NUMBER
OF MONTHS.
YOU LISTENED TO THE GOVERNOR AS
HE RESIGNED YESTERDAY AFTER HE
EXPLAINED HOW INNOCENT HE WAS.
YOU SAY THE GOVERNOR FOR ANOTHER
13 DAYS IS DELUSIONAL.
EXPLAIN WHY.
>> I’M SORRY, REPEAT THAT
QUESTION AGAIN?
I JUST GOT -- I’M HEARING JANICE
CRYING I’M A LITTLE EMOTIONAL
MYSELF.
I’M SORRY, REPEAT THAT QUESTION.
STEVE: YOU SAID YOU FEEL THE
GOVERNOR IS DELUSIONAL AFTER
LISTENING TO HIM RESIGN
YESTERDAY.
>> WELL, IT WASN’T AN APOLOGY.
HE IS NOT TAKING RESPONSIBILITY
TO THE BITTER END TO REFLECTIVE
OF THE LACK OF LEADERSHIP IN
THAT OFFICE FOR SO MANY YEARS.
THE WOMAN WHO HAD WERE SEXUALLY
HARASSED THE OLDER ADULTS
JUSTICE WE HAVE BEEN SEEKING
DESERVE APOLOGY AND FULL
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT’S NOT
WHAT WE GOT OUT OF HIM
YESTERDAY.
BRIAN: HE WARNED WITH YOU NOT
GOING FORWARD WITH ATTACKING ON
NURSING HOMES.
HE COULD CARE LESS ABOUT YOUR
RELATIVES THAT LOST YOUR LIFE,
YOUR UNCLE.
THAT WAS A TURNING POINT FOR
YOU.
INSTEAD OF BEING INTIMIDATED,
YOU TOOK ACTION.
WHAT DID THAT DO FOR YOU
PERSONALLY?
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT DID FOR
THIS CASE?
IT WASN’T JUST ME IN THAT
MOMENT.
THOUSANDS OF OTHER FAMILIES.
A NUMBER OF OTHER PEOPLE.
BRIAN: NOT LAWMAKERS.
>> AND I LOST MY UNCLE, A U.S.
ARMY CAPTAIN IN A NURSING HOME
DYING EXCRUCIATING PAIN.
IF IT WASN’T FOR MY UNCLE, I
WOULDN’T BE HERE.
MEANING HE SPONSORED MY
IMMIGRATION PAPER TO COME TO
THIS COUNTRY SO I CAN BE PART OF
THIS AMERICAN DREAM.
THIS AMERICAN FABRIC.
AND FOR HIM TO DIE ALONE LIKE
THAT I MADE A COMMITMENT THAT I
WOULD SEEK THE TRUTH FOR HIM AND
FOR OTHERS IN THAT MOMENT WHAT
ANDREW CUOMO TRIED TO GET ME TO
LIE AND TO COVER UP HIS LIES,
THAT WAS THE MOMENT HE CROSSED
FROM BEING A REGULAR BULLY IN A
PLAYGROUND TO AN ABUSIVE MAN WHO
IS WILLING TO ABUSE HIS POWER TO
GET WHAT HE WANTS.
AINSLEY: JANICE WHAT DID YOU
MAKE OF THE PRESIDENT SAYING
YESTERDAY HE IS NOT A BAD MAN.
HIS POLICIES.
STEVE: DID A HELL OF A JOB.
JANICE: I THOUGHT THAT VIDEOTAPE
WAS LAST YEAR PRAISING HIM WHEN
HE WAS GOING TO BE HIS ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
I THINK JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO LEARN
THE FACTS ABOUT WHAT THIS
GOVERNOR HAS DONE.
NOT ONLY THE NURSING HOMES AND
SHOWER.
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT.
HE GIVES TO GIVE COVID TESTS TO
HIS BUDDIES AND FRIENDS WHILE
NURSING HOMES COULD NOT GET
THEM.
HE USED STATE RESOURCE WAS WRITE
HIS BOOK AND ALL SORTS OF OTHER
CORRUPTION AND I THINK CRIMINAL
ACTS THAT HOPEFULLY WILL BE
PROSECUTED SO I WAS VERY
DISAPPOINTED IN JOE BIDEN
YESTERDAY.
AINSLEY: YOU BOTH HAVE SAID HE
TRIED TO INTIMIDATE YOU GUYS.
JANICE, TELL YOUR STORY ABOUT
THAT AND THEN TELL YOUR STORY.
AINSLEY: NOT LIKE ASSEMBLYMAN
KIM I HEARD FROM MINIONS SHE IS
NOT RELIABLE SOURCE ON ANYTHING
EXCEPT THE WEATHER.
I HEARD FROM A FAMILY FRIEND OF
THEIRS EARLY ON WHO TOLD ME,
LISTEN, YOU HAVE A NOBLE CAUSE
HERE BUT PLEASE WATCH YOUR BACK.
LISTEN, SOCIAL MEDIA IS NO FUN
EITHER.
PEOPLE SAYING WEATHER LADY YOU
DON’T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
RON AND I HAD A PURPOSE.
WE WERE AFFECTED PERSONALLY THAT
RAMPED OUR CAUSE UP QUITE A BIT.
AINSLEY: ASSEMBLYMAN?
>> JANICE HAS BEEN PERSISTENT
THROUGH THIS FIGHT.
SHE HAS BEEN PSYCHOLOGICALLY
IMPACTED AND HER FAMILY FOR
MONTHS.
SO I APPLAUD HER.
THE FIGHT IS NOT OVER.
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO PARTNER
WITH HER TO GET TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE DESERVE
IN TERMS OF INTIMIDATION YES, MY
FAMILY FELT THREATENED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
WHEN I GOT THAT CALL AND
MULTIPLE CALLS FROM HIM DIRECTLY
MY WIFE COULDN’T SLEEP FOR
HOURS.
MY FAMILY WERE TRAUMATIZED BY
THAT EXPERIENCE.
BUT WE CAME TOGETHER AS A
FAMILY.
WE GOT SUPPORT FROM PEOPLE LIKE
JANICE WHO WAS THERE FROM THE
BEGINNING, TO GIVE US THE
STRENGTH TO PUSH BACK AND DEMAND
JUSTICE FROM THIS GOVERNOR.
STEVE: INDEED.
SPEAKING OF JUSTICE, RON.
HE IS STILL ON THE HOOK.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE STILL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
NURSING HOME SCANDAL, INTO
WHETHER OR NOT STATE RESOURCES
WERE USED TO HELP WRITE HIS BOOK
AND SO, YOU KNOW, HE IS NOT OUT
OF THE WOODS.
THERE IS STILL A LONG WAY FOR
HIM TO GO.
AND THE LEGISLATURE COULD VOTE
TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
WE SHOULD ABSOLUTELY DO.
SO WE SPENT THE RESOURCES TIME
AND MONEY TO GET THIS FAR IN THE
IMPEACHMENT INVESTIGATION.
SO LET’S FINISH THE JOB.
LET’S GET IT DONE AND EFFICIENT
EXPEDITIOUS WAY TO GET TO THE
TRUTH.
AS FOR HIS CRIMINAL ACT, HIS
BIGGEST CRIMINAL ACT IN MY
OPINION IS COMMITTING PUBLIC
FRAUD.
HE SUPPRESSED.
HE ORDERED HIS FEEL SUPPRESS
LIFE AND DEATH DATA AT THE PEAK
OF THE PANDEMIC.
INFORMATION WE COULD HAVE USED
TO LEGISLATE AND SAVE PEOPLE’S
LIVES HE TOOK THAT AWAY FROM US
BECAUSE HE WAS CHASING DOWN A
$5.1 MILLION BOOK DEAL.
THAT IS CRIMINAL.
BRIAN: IS HE GOING TO BLAME WILL
DER ROSA WHO WAS ON THAT PHONE
CALL AND CLAIM HE NEVER KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT IT IS HE PLANNING
A COMEBACK ALREADY.
THAT’S WHY HIS LAWYER WAS ON
FIRST AND TRIED TO EXPLAIN
HIMSELF RATHER THAN SIMPLY
RESIGN.
JANICE, I DON’T THINK THIS GUY
IS DONE, DO YOU?
JANICE: I THINK HE IS DONE.
I HAVE TO BELIEVE WE ARE ON THE
SIDE OF THE ANGELS, RON KIM AND
I AND OUR FAMILIES.
HE’S DONE.
BRIAN: RON, DO YOU THINK HE
THINKS HE IS DONE.
>> I BELIEVE HE IS POLITICALLY
CON BUT KNOWING HIM HE IS
PROBABLY THINKING OF SOME SORT
OF A COMEBACK PLAN AND IT’S UP
TO US TO HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE
AND EXPOSE THE TRUTH SO HE --
THERE IS NO WAY FOR HIM TO COME
BACK INTO THE PUBLIC SPACE.
ESPECIALLY IN HE GETS
IMIMPEACHED.
JANICE: I LOVE YOU RON I LOVE
YOUR FAMILY THANK YOU.